hi this is a joint work with my
collaborator styles interval so so here
is the common machinery procedure so
what happens is that there are many
machine learning algorithms which
involve one or more parameters so for
example you know most popular example
the scheme means where you know this is
parameter T the number of clusters or if
you're doing in its embassy of
histograms then you know there's the bin
size or if you're looking at
classification there are regularization
parameters and to be honest nobody
really knows how to set these parameters
properly so what people do is you know
they they you know they have this
training data set and then the train for
a bunch of values of the parameters so
you know they try let's say you know 10
values of the regularization parameters
or 10 values of the number of clusters
they get 10 results they use a
validation data set to figure out which
of these perform the best and then you
know whichever performs the best on the
validation set is output right and this
is called the training and validation
procedure or and you know in any kind of
practical machine learning system this
is this is used extensively okay so the
question that we would be looking at
today is how do we execute this kind of
a training and validation process
privately and of course by privacy I
mean differential privacy so here is the
definition of differential privacy I
don't really need to repeat it at this
workshop but I would like to make one
quick point here is here i'm going to
call epsilon the privacy parameter i'm
going to call it the privacy budget okay
so what are the properties of
differential privacy well so it has a
number of excellent properties and here
are a couple of them that I'm going to
use later on in the talk right so the
first thing to note is you know how do
we design differentially private
algorithms well you know differentially
private algorithms they are all their
randomized algorithms and usually the
key idea involved in designing these
algorithms is that you add some kind of
noise or randomness and the goal of this
noise or randomness is to hide the
effect of one person's value
because in one person's value shouldn't
make a big difference so you try to hide
the effect on one person's value when
you output the differentially private
algorithms the second property that you
know we would kind of use and this talk
about is what happens when you do data
use so if you you know if you apply a
hobo on the same data set if you apply a
bunch of differentially private
algorithms then you know then then your
privacy risk gets worse and for example
you know the simplest such statement is
that if you reuse the same data k times
with epsilon differential privacy you
get K epsilon differential privacy and
then there are much more stronger
statements when you look at epsilon
delta differential privacy by war crowd
plum and vuitton and more recently by o
anveshana okay and so what are the
trade-offs when you want to do you know
machine learning or statistics or any
kind of data analysis with differential
privacy so it turns out that there is
typically a three-way trade off and the
trade-offs are between privacy accuracy
and sample size so what you could do is
you could get both privacy and accuracy
but your cost is going to be a lot more
data and similarly you know if you
sacrifice for example if you are willing
to sacrifice or accuracy then you could
get privacy and sample size and vice
versa and as we will see you over the
top that this thing will show up okay
okay so why does training and validation
you know what is the problem when we try
to do it the differential privacy so you
know let's look at this procedure or
here what we are doing is you know we
are trying to do everything with
differential privacy we are using you
know so each training parameter you know
we are training for a bunch of parameter
values every time you use privacy
epsilon right and then we are doing
valuation and then we have the output
the problem here is that we are using
the training data are a whole bunch of
times right in fact k times 4k parameter
values and as a result the privacy
budget is exceeded right so the privacy
budget you stop is K epsilon whereas we
were hoping that we could get away with
that salam okay so so what would what
could you do so we know here are two
no very naive approaches one thing is
you take your privacy budget you split
it in two key portions and then while
you are doing training so for each you
know each time you do training you use a
privacy budget of epsilon over K right
and you know this would work this would
give you an answer but the problem is
because we used a lower privacy budget
and training what would happen is we
would get less accuracy right because
you remember the three-way trade of
privacy accuracy and sample size we keep
the sample size fix we are using a lower
privacy budget right so most requests
more strict about privacy so we would
get less accuracy okay the other kind of
you know baseline approach that we could
think about is you take your training
data set and you divide it into a bunch
of disjoint sets right so you divided
into K disjoint sets and you know
everyone you train you train with each
of the disjoint sets right in this case
because the sets at this joint you know
you you would still get privacy budget
use would be epsilon but because you're
using less training data again the
solution is going to be suboptimal right
so you would have less accuracy because
you are using less training data in
doing the training okay so what we
conclude is that you know both of these
approaches could be suboptimal and the
question is whether we can do better and
it don't solve that indeed that is the
case under certain conditions and we
would you know go go ahead and identify
these conditions okay so we call our
condition the stability condition so
this is a bit different from the other
kinds of stability that already talked
about so this is a different kind of
civility condition so before we define
the condition let me I need a couple of
definitions right so the first thing i
would like to define is the validation
score because remember we talked about
you know we used the validation data set
to determine which of these training
sets output which of them was the best
right and the validation score is the
measure of you know quality there right
so it is best according to this
validation score so the validation score
is a function which takes two arguments
the first is the output of the training
procedure and the sec
is a validation set and the larger this
is it means your performance is better
okay so now let's look at what the
validation process where the validation
process is trying to achieve so here are
the parameters you have a training set T
you have a validation said me you have
some parameter set P you have a training
algorithm and the validation score right
so what you could do is for each
parameter you know each parameter in P
you could look at the output of the
training algorithm with that parameter
and the training data and then you could
compute the score based on the you could
compute a validation score based on the
validation data right and what you would
like to do is to find the parameter in
the inner parameter set that privately
you know or approximately maximizes this
disk where this validation score okay so
you know as we know it so to do this we
need to hide the effect of one person's
value right so when kandi scorers change
so these course will change when one
person in be changes right so validation
set changes this course can change
moving up and down a lil don't saw these
course will also change when one
person's value in the training set
changes right because if we change your
training set a little whatever output of
the training set you would get would
also change a little and then the score
changes in the side and and don't so
that that is key in our approach so in
the standard method when you do the
analysis what you would do is you would
assume that the event so remember is a
randomized algorithm so the event that
would hold is a of t comma P is equal to
a of T prime comma P where t prime is
one step away from T and then assuming
this even holds you would use some kind
of noisy maximization to hide the effect
of change or one person's value in the
validation set and what we do is to use
noisy maximization to hide the change in
T and V together so that is that is the
key idea behind this work okay so how do
we do that let's try to formalize so
before I formalize let me use one more
definition so
i am going to represent a differentially
private algorithm in a slightly
different way from what you're
accustomed ok so this algorithm a
because it's a randomized algorithm I
can write it as a tuple the first item
in the tuple is a distribution G sub a
which is independent of the after of the
sensitive data and the second item in
the tuple is a function f sub a right so
what happens is and the procedure can be
looked at as follows you draw a random
series of random numbers from G sub a
and then you've output F sub a of d and
you know various other parameters and
our where r is the random number that
you drew from G sub a right and i would
like to remark that f sub a is
deterministic right so essentially the
randomness is concentrated in the draw
from our and you know you draw some
random number and you all put a function
of the random number which it's a
deterministic function ok so so here is
the training stability condition that we
need so suppose you are you have a score
q its we call if we see that it's be one
Delta training stable with respect to
our training algorithm a a parameter set
P and a privacy budget Epsilon if for
all parameters in the set for all
validation sets and which probability 1
minus Delta over this R if you change
your training set by one person and if
you keep your random draw are fixed then
thus 0 then the validation score will
not change very much right so here in
this equation you know be one over the
size of the training set measures how
much it would change and the key point
is that we are keeping the same random
value fixed right so we are keeping the
same random value are fixed and we are
changing one person's value in the
training set and we are looking at home
and we are keeping everything else fixed
and we are looking at how much the
validation score changes okay so this is
training stability the next thing is
validation stability and you know let me
remark that this is actually much more
standard so what this says is that if
you you know if you keep the essentially
the training part is the same so the
output of the training procedures are
the same but if you
change one person's value in the
validation set then the score does not
change too much the validation score
does not change too much okay and we
will say you know something has this
entire procedure has B 1 B 2 Delta
stability if it has v1 Dells are trading
stability and B 2 delta validation
stability okay so so now we have defined
the stability condition let's look at
how this will give us better private
validation so remember this was the
problem that we are trying to solve we
were trying to find a parameter value to
privately maximize this validation score
what we do here is we look at the max of
the the changes due to the change in the
training set and the validation set we
for each parameter value we calculate
the score and we add noise which is
proportional to that better which is the
max right and then we output so we add
this noise to each score and then be
output the the parameter value in the
set P that maximizes that the noisy
score okay and so essentially again the
the key you know intuition here is that
we are looking into you know how much
the score changes when training and
validation changes and what and then
this is our full algorithm what we do is
you know we do the training we get a
bunch of we get a bunch of let's say the
outputs of the training algorithm we use
our validation procedure and we get the
parameter value we do a retraining with
this parameter value and then we do this
output and it turns out so in our paper
we have to use this procedure it turns
out that we can you know in some more
recent work we can remove the retraining
step as well so there so we would you
know directly output CI but anyway so
for the purpose of this talk we do some
retraining and we get the output and
this is what we can show if the
validation score has this B 1 V 2 delta
/ case tape stability property with
respect to the training algorithm the
parameter set and the privacy budget
epsilon over to then the whole procedure
is actually
enter private so you know before what
what would happen is we would have to
use epsilon over K for training and now
you know what's what's happening is that
we are using epsilon over 2 so okay so i
have defined this i know trading
stability straining and validation
stability property and i have shown you
that you know once this property holds
we can get good validation you know good
validation procedures now the question
is you know when does this whole right
and so we have two examples in our paper
one is linear classification and I'm
going to tell you in more detail about
linear classification another one is
histogram density estimation so for that
it would have to look at the paper and
you know these are two very basic
problems in statistics and machine
learning so and so let us look in more
detail at linear classification so a
little classification what happens is
that we are given a whole bunch of label
vectors which are drawn from some high
dimensional space and so these vectors
come from a distribution P over labeled
examples and what we do want to do is to
find a vector that separates the pluses
and minuses for most points from this
distribution and the key here which you
know the you know which is the basis of
a lot of theory of video statistics and
machine learning is to find so remember
that you know these are drawn from the
distribution so we are not just
interested in separating the training
data but also future points that come
from the distribution and it don't saw
that the key here so that you know so
that it generalizes well is to find a
simple model that would fit the training
samples so one of the ways to do it is
by empirical risk minimization and you
know this can be you know this can be
made private and let me tell you because
of the shortage of time let me tell you
a little bit about one of the private
algorithms right so one of the private
algorithms which was in in our previous
work was the following you are given a
bunch of label data xinyi what you want
to do is to find a
w that maximizes the sum of three terms
right so the first term is you know half
lambda at the norm of W square and this
term is called the regularization term
and it measures the model complexity the
second term is sum over all the training
data points some L of why I w transpose
x I and in some sense this is called the
risk this is something that measures the
training error in some sense and the
third term is a perturbation term and so
this is a you know one over n B
transpose W where B is a certain
perturbation vector which is drawn in a
certain way and this is the term that
gives you privacy so you look at a
convex optimization problem which is the
sum of these three terms and then you
solve it and then the answer that you
get will give you differential privacy
provided certain conditions on the loss
function holds okay and so for example
one of the things that you could do is
you could take the risk the L the
functional to be logistic loss which is
again a commonly used you know the
commonly used law seems by machine
learners and what you would get at the
end by optimizing is a private logistic
regression okay so and here is what we
can show about private logistic
regression so here again remember the
parameter was the regularization
parameter lambda it's not immediate
apparently you know just by looking at
at it how to set lambda and in practice
again people do this training validation
process it depends on your data set so
you know it sir so the parameter here is
a regularization parameter lambda is for
validation score we use sorry the
negative of any L Lipschitz loss so you
know typically one of the things that
you may want to use is the
classification loss so we can't you know
do it with the classification loss
because it's not it's not smooth it
jumps but if you have any L Lipschitz
loss it works so your validation score
is the negative of any L Lipschitz loss
and what you can show is that this Q is
this validation score
is better one better to delta stable
with respect to the training algorithm a
if you have a set of lambdas and the
privacy budget epsilon if sorry if b1
and b2 are these particular numbers so
b1 is going to be twice and Ellis the
Lipschitz Nets over lambda min this is
the minimum land and you're set and b2
is going to be the minimum of the max
value that you could take and this
quantity right LOL andaman times this
quantity and so in this quantity and
finally we you know we look at some
experiments and some preliminary
experiments with this method so the
methods that we are using are you know
obviously a stability is our method we
look at data split the method we talked
about where we you know use this joint
training data sets epsilon split the
method where we split the privacy budget
epsilon random is where we just pick a
random value of lambda and control is
where you know this is like an only
seein method which knows the right value
of lambda okay and the thing to notice
is that random and control already have
a bit of an advantage because they don't
use any privacy budget so we assume that
you can take the entire epsilon to Train
they don't use any privacy budget to
find anything right so they have an
inherent advantage and the two data sets
that we used our the dull data set and
we kind of did some feature selection to
bring the dimensions down to 250 two
dimensions in about 45 thousand samples
and then another data set called magic
notices again another UCI data set where
we had 10 dimensions in about nineteen
thousand samples and we divided the data
into no training set validation and test
sets so the results are reported on the
test sets how well they do was reported
on the test sets where the training set
was eighty percent validation set was
ten percent and assets desert was ten
percent and is a kind of typical values
that people use while doing these kinds
of experiments what again is the control
our control is when you are you know
when you are only saying that you know
what you're right lambda was in the set
and here are some results with mean
square error so on the x axis we have
epsilon the pink line is control so
control is when you you know when you
were omniscient I bet you knew what
lambda was and you could use your entire
budget for privacy budget for training
and so it's no surprise that it does the
best right so lower means better okay
yes yeah because it's sure it knows
lambda but it's train is still training
using differentially private training
right signals yeah okay the two green
lines are essentially epsilon split and
data state right so the two green lines
are when you know you know when you are
yes also i guess the two green lines are
essentially when you are doing this
procedure where you are either dividing
the data into k k parks i think here k
was maybe seven i have to look up the
paper but the k was seven when you are
doing the training over the k parts or
you are splitting your data into kate is
john sections and random is again you
pick a random value of lambda from the
set and you just train with that but to
get me know you have a slight advantage
in the sudden since that you are using
the entire privacy budget for training
okay and the red line is stability so as
you can see that in the beginning when
the privacy budget is very small
stability is doing slightly better than
you know alpha epsilon split and data
split but not too much but as your
privacy budget increases slowly
stability does better and better and
finally it does about as well as as well
as control which is that I did yes so
just to understand how much for
I don't exactly remember so my
qualitative experiments I don't exactly
remember a question for it so the reason
for the noise in the stability in the
day or instability can you separate it
so if you are doing actually to
computation trustee of estimating the
farm atopy and then your than epsilon
personal private computation oh but then
if if one is more dominant maybe you
want to send more epsilon no surprise
about it in computing season that is a
very good question so what Kobe is
saying is that you know instead of
splitting epsilon over 2x and Roberto
maybe you could split you know epsilon
over you know 3 and 2 epsilon over 3 for
the training so for this these
experiments you're absolutely right and
I suspect that those would definitely
help but for these experiments we
haven't done that opsonization you're
absolutely right that would definitely
help so we have here use half-and-half
we haven't looked into that and so in
conclusion we provided a generic
validation procedure which would work
provided the serviceability conditions
hold we showed that it applies to
regular as linear classification and
histogram we have also shown in our
paper that you know if you want to use
histograms to do density estimation then
these things will also work and for
future work you know one of the works is
to remove the retraining step which we
have kind of done and we are in the
process of writing it up and it also
applies and find in a more other
learning problem so find some more
generic conditions under which leaves
this couldn't you know you could do this
kind of a procedure
so if you go back to your beta 1 and
beta 2 for typical settings is one was
larger than the other um that is a good
question so that kind of depends on how
you choose your training set size and
validation sets so if your training set
size is quite large then you know then
this would be small right so this part
would be small so gentlemanly your
training set size has to be about the
you know for the training algorithm the
work has to be what the log DK over
Delta over epsilon right and so this is
this is kind of a constant then the q
let's is usually so okay so for Q max is
so here what we used was we use the loss
call ramp last to choose the validation
so r + + is just a smooth version of 0 1
loss so they are actually q max was
founded by one so they so that that was
good actually it would be one yeah so
can their q max first one is make you
much so sponsored a vision LOL nominee
was larger than yeah but if you use
something like you know his loss or
logistic loss for even for the
validation then it could be unbounded
and then this would be the this is
whatever it is yes so you can imagine
their cases where
parameter the privacy primer depends on
some other parameter of the algorithm as
well the colonel bandwidth or something
weird like that is that sort of is there
any case is there any case where somehow
you can't do this just generic because
somehow the second step over with okay
everybody I'll take off like literally
nothing
you